una apuesta decidida por el clima
el presidente francés emmanuel macon
reunió este miércoles en el elíseo a una
docena de expertos en clima y cambio
climático para poner en marcha su
prometida planificación ecológica a las
puertas de su segundo quinquenio está
llamada a la comunidad científica busca
sentar las bases de su proyecto en
materia medioambiental uno de los
estandartes de su campaña electoral los
kings
notificó esos lapsos es mejor que la
comunidad científica en el sentido más
amplio participe en las decisiones se
implique en la gestión administrativa
ese es el papel del consejo superior del
clima también es el rol de una comunidad
científica como la nuestra que cuando
nos llaman los políticos podamos
responder he sido friki confusión y
retos si comenzamos poniendo los macro
comprometió en campaña que convertirá a
francia en la primera gran nación libre
de petróleo gas y carbón el presidente
adoptó la propuesta de planificación
ecológica de su rival político el
progresista jean-luc mélenchon quien ya
firmó un pacto con los ecologistas de
cara a las elecciones legislativas del
próximo 12 y 19 de junio a poco más de
un mes de la nueva cita con las urnas
macrón se comprometió a que su no el
primer ministro se encargará
específicamente del reto climático que
enfrenta francia y podemos sentir en
este planteamiento de manuel macro no
creo la importancia que la edad ha hecho
muchas promesas en esta materia lo vimos
en marsella y ahora se trata asimismo de
cómo pasar estas promesas a la acción
concretas los próximos cinco años van a
ser esenciales en lo que respecta a la
lucha contra el calentamiento global y
el respeto de los objetivos establecidos
en la legislación está lejos de estar
conquistado y tampoco es fácil el
gobierno francés defendió hoy su apuesta
por el clima después de que el consejo
de estado le pidiera medidas más
concretas para cumplir sus compromisos
del acuerdo de parís